They’ve had enough: Enough of Thailand’s
military rulers, enough of seeing their rights
curtailed, enough of promised elections being
pushed back time and time again.
Now, these protesters in the heart of Bangkok
say, they won’t back down until the government
makes good on its promise to let the people
have their say.
We’ve been living with a parliament that
has no opposition for the last five years,
without any good governance, no opposition
working in the parliament.
So this election is very important for Thailand,
not only to go back to democracy but also
to form the country back again.
And to get their rights as citizens back.
In the past five years, the military government
has used its power to stop critics from speaking
out.
Until recently, protests like this one were
prohibited by the strict assembly law Thailand’s
military dictatorship put in place.
Now that law has been lifted but inspite of
that protesters are still telling me they’re
being harassed by the authorities.
Last time, before I came to the demonstration,
the police called me and he tried to convince
me and force me to not participate in the
demonstration and he tried to force me to
go with him to the coffee shop and just put
me in the coffee shop until the demonstration
ended.+o+
But these tactics aren’t keeping activists
away.
They’re afraid the government could play
for time until the election deadline set by
Thailand’s constitution expires.
Then, there would be no telling when Thais
would get to vote again.